imagine if we made excuses for each  other we'd become a more loving nation I  found out often we are very harsh with  people they may be facing problems that  aren't visible to us I once had to go  back a friend who was late for our  meeting little did I know his mother was  admitted to hospital he was devastated  we are quick to jump to conclusions and  be disappointed with each other I could  have said to myself maybe something  happened maybe his baby kept him up all  night and he did it sleep until 4am  maybe he's got a massive universities  design and he's struggling to juggle  work i wish i had just embraced him when  we finally met our selfishness leads us  to forget people around us are human  there are moments when it's okay to make  excuses for people